gather round everybody get your blankets
turn out the lights and get a snack
because it's time for a very scary story
that was weirdly timed this is tiny
bunny apparently it's a good time for
indie games because this is also one of
the highest rated games on steam
it's a visual novel but it's a visual
novel where your choices
matter every choice that i make is going
to affect the outcome of this game
and determine well something i actually
don't know much about the game itself
but think of it as a fairy tale
maybe a cautionary tale but a fairy tale
nonetheless
about you and me
and a tiny bunny that was very hot
turn the volume up and put your
headphones on
i think this is going to be a sensory
experience
the wind clawed at my window all night
long
it wandered the fields and howled like a
hungry beast
an endless song weaved from all sorts of
voices
shrill gentle sneery
twined in the air they were shouting and
laughing
and arguing about something someone was
running through the snow while casting
long shadows that would occasionally
creep close to my bed
our house had a mind of its own the
creaky old mind of a building that had
seen a lot in its days
and was seemingly trying to share its
wisdom with the inhabitants
the lonely house faced the forest and
the dark green thicket gazed back with
its hollow eyes
rustling whizzing swaying back and forth
one could come out and stand at the edge
of the forest to reassure themselves
there was nobody behind the crooked
trees fuzzy silhouettes swaying in the
wind couldn't possibly
do any harm it's just a play of
light and shadow
just to play i knew it was my
imagination
i was already 12 after all still
[Music]
ooh
the only one that saw that did you guys
see that
hey put away your book
how many times have i told you not to
read at the table it's bad for your
health
look at how swatched you are yeah
reading's bad kids hide oh whoops oh
wait what
what oh oh that was a choice
had already finished her breakfast and
was munching on some cookies
she was so enthusiastic she almost
looked like your typical girl from
commercials
you're not going anywhere until you
finish all of it
i on the other hand was still trying to
drill a hole in the plate with my eyes
as if it would make the porridge
disappear
hazy anxiousness welled up inside all
because of the previous sleepless night
the black forest around our house and
the gloomy wind
the longer i waited the colder the lumpy
white substance became
it looked like a jellyfish from the
costo odyssey
i love that show we got a nerd alert
sound the nerd alarm
i wonder how horrifying the bottom of
the ocean is never mind cancel the nerd
alarm this guy is totally relatable and
i get
what he's saying or how cold the black
forest is at night
the spoon fell out of my hand mom
showered me with a cold glare from a
green eyes
what did i just say i'll get it
i had 10 seconds to catch my breath
before battling the nasty porridge once
again
what is this carved on the other side of
the table
carina hey that's my mom's name
i guess she carved it out with something
pointy when she was little
she sure was a rascal damaging the
furniture like that
i imagined her being my age sitting
under this table
i wonder was mom afraid of the dark back
then
i imagined my grandma coming into my
little mom's room
sitting at the edge of her bed where
olya sleeps nowadays
and saying this in her soft smooth voice
hi guys a special place little girl
it's watching you closely sniffing you
out
trying to discern what kind of beast you
are
if you're a good sword it won't abandon
you in times of trouble
but if you're a bad apple it'll grab you
by the side and drag you under the
ground
and that would be it grandma was caring
she never fought with anybody
never yelled never swore those were the
times without the maddening screams
until late at night
without smashed dishes and mutual
accusations
our parents used to love each other back
then
i remember listening in on one of their
conversations by chance
they were talking about grandma getting
prepared for her funeral
she had already bought a casket i know
that feeling and she called it her
cute funeral box it waited for its time
in the closet
patiently it was black upholstered with
meat-colored material on the inside
i saw it when my grandma was getting
buried
the house didn't change since the time
she was alive
only all the photos were gone i crawled
out from under the table
oya was done with her cookies and was
looking at my share like a sly woodland
critter
i turned my gaze towards the frosted
window oh you look it's a fox
where it looked almost like those
optical illusion thingies they put on
the back of student notebooks
look here's the nose and here's hey eat
up yes yes
just a moment who talks to their mom
like that my dad entered the kitchen
with long measured steps
i want to have a beard like his when i
grow up
mom would always ask jokingly come on
shave it off it stings
this was long so long ago nowadays
rumbling doors and witty comebacks were
an everyday occurrence
olia always covers your ears when she
hears something like what's the point in
all this through the wall
i always caught every sound of fear of
hearing the most dreaded deadliest word
that started with a d
d-i-v-o i don't even want to finish it
it was scary to imagine that me and my
little sister could be torn apart
and taken into two different families
anyway your fox is nothing i have an owl
on my window
you and your owl talk again you said you
believed me yesterday
there was no owl but there was
one it had giant glowing eyes
well you sprung up from the chair and
placed her hands on her little face
imitating a pair of eyes with her
fingers the size of an apple each
last year you had babai in your closet
now this
buh-bye but i saw it
well you shifted her gaze back and forth
from her dad to mom to me but couldn't
find any support oh you pouted her lips
in rebellion and rushed into the hallway
the staircase that led to the second
floor creaked
mom gave dad a strict look oh that look
in her eyes
so uncomfortable to be pinned under it a
minute had passed and
the theme song from the little mermaid
echoed through the house
it was stored on incredibly worn out
cassette tape which dad already had to
glue together once
it's so easy to fix objects by gluing
them back together for example
but how do you fix a relationship these
are not the thoughts that a 12 year old
should be pondering
yeah had trouble sleeping ever since we
moved to this house she would toss and
turn
or curl up into a ball under her blanket
sometimes she would jump
up in the middle of the night and turn
on the vcr cartoons helped to take her
mind off the troubles we had with the
move
and our parents
and then all you said she saw that giant
flying monster
outside her window she became obsessed
with it
our parents did everything in their
power they tried every little trick to
get rid of those ridiculous fears
ollie refused to sleep alone and didn't
believe that the owl was just one of her
nightmares
after tonight i was unsure what to make
of my sister's words
what to think of it myself can
nightmares be infectious
just last night i couldn't get a wink of
sleep and ended up thinking of what to
expect in my new school
there were a couple of days left before
the beginning of a new term
my imagination drew long twisting
hallways that led to a classroom full of
kids
but all the students behind their desks
were simply dark figures cut out
using a template circular holes
gaped in the middle of their faces and
pairs of eyes blinked inside those holes
it was as if some completely different
creatures were looking at me from behind
the flat black silhouettes
the cruel glares filled with icy sneers
made me shiver
from head to toe will i survive here
the damn school can burn for all i care
i just wish for anything to happen to it
doesn't really matter what i didn't want
to go there that badly
i didn't want to see people who were
just itching to smack me on the head
trip me up think of a new offensive name
for me worse than the previous one
my gaze slid across the drawings hanging
in the walls
i couldn't consider myself a great
artist but oya begged me to hang them
drawing was the only thing that made me
happy as of late the small circle of
friends i had also enjoyed my paintings
and they promised to call me from time
to time sometimes i imagine bomb picking
up the phone and saying in a cold voice
you've got the wrong number anton
is not around anton's not around
something was watching me from every
corner almost as if the old photos of my
diseased
family with their ash and eyes were
hanging on the walls in place of my
drawings
the floor was squeaky rusty drains were
moaning
the attic was occupied by noisy drafts
one could think the house was performing
some sort of demonic melody
and then i realized i was in fact
hearing music
it was already playing for a good while
somewhere at the edge of my perception
i could hear a flute it was mixed in
with the sound of the wind
of the creaking old house in my thoughts
too
i stood up and rushed to the window i
wanted to reassure myself that this
music was nothing more than a product of
my own imagination
black silhouettes i could barely make
out with the dark forest as their
backdrop
they jumped around basked in the
moonlight bumped into piles of snow
rolled around and crawled on all fours
stories about wolves playing under the
moon came to mind
but these were clearly not wolves they
stood upright at times
circled around holding hands and
whipping up snow disappearing into the
shadows
for a brief moment and then coming back
something bizarre was going on shadows
dancing in the starless abyss made my
imagination go wild
made me anxious at the same time
suddenly the music stopped
the dancing shadows frozen place and i
could swear
pierced me with their eyes one of the
silhouettes immediately parted from the
bizarre
shadow carnival and spread it across the
field with giant leaps
i shut the curtains with a swift motion
and stepped back towards the bed
they saw me a freezing torn of fear
washed over me
i stood in the middle of a perfectly
dark room and listened to some unwanted
guests move
and scrape around i jumped into the bed
and covered myself with the blanket as
if it could protect me
i remember the funeral my grandma lying
there hands crossed on her chest
her facial features sharp like that of a
tin doll
ants running up and down the legs of
chairs that held my grandma's casket
i imagine those little creatures
climbing up her head and pulling up her
eyelids with her tiny legs
then her wrinkly eyeballs would once
again move inside their sockets
and she'd be able to see her
grandchildren
and now lying under the blanket and
listening to squeaks and howls i was
reading the same words
on the island of bouyon underneath the
blemish sun
in the sea of color blue stands a cabin
made of wood
there lay lard and ashen hair for the
spawn from devil's lair
to feast and always leave alone god's
faithful servant named antone
evil leave this house must ashes to
ashes
dust to dust bizarre sounds it
disappeared
and then the night doused me with a new
portion of boiling terror
the sound scratched at my eardrums in
reality something or someone was
scratching at the front door
hurriedly crawling at the wood demanding
to be let in the door was shut the
doorknob twitched
slightly then it turned halfway
once twice as if the person who tried
enter had no hands
the doorknob tilted once more and then
started clicking violently
my jaw cramped from fear my wet fingers
clutched the blanket
the door creaked it open the wind
taunted me moaning inside the tin drains
now now you'll see
the darkness rised inside the
carnivorous mouth of a doorway
pony tony
it was if the night itself was calling
out to me
flapping its black wings and squeaking
with rusty hingers
i was trembling ensnared by the web of
darkness that hung in the corners of my
room
waiting for the one who weaved it to
come out of the gaping black hole
tony tony
my abdomen tightened and my chest rose
up ready to exhale a
desperate scream but before i was able
to do anything
the darkness asked me tony
you asleep my sister's pale face
protruded from thick shadows
i almost screamed from relief
oh yeah i'm i'm not sleeping
did something happen well you frowned
and stuck out her lower lip
a clear sign that she was about to cry
it's there again
staring at me sure away tony
please i was so scared
the fear that was tormenting me just a
minute ago crawled away and hid
somewhere in my stomach
i needed to calm all you down all right
let's watch cinderella
what was that what studied me with its
eyes while dancing feverishly under the
moon
tony you coming yeah
yeah just a moment
that's why i didn't want to laugh at all
again or owl in the morning
oh ding dong hey how you doing
who could be visiting us here in the
middle of nowhere
we don't know anyone around here bang
bong
so persistent a couple of policemen
towered over me in the doorway
hello the senior officer who wore a grim
expression
nodded a boy had gone missing yesterday
his name's vova look at this please have
you seen him
the policeman held out a photograph to
me
i've never seen this boy in my life
there was a ginger boy around the age of
11 illuminatory school
no i haven't are you sure look closely
where would i see him i don't know
anyone around here i barely leave the
house
well maybe you've seen him from the
window that's right your windows look
straight at the forest don't they
the window no i haven't seen anything
i see he sounded tired but his eyes
his stare long and heavy was full of
suspicion
little boys like you should stay at home
and steer away from trouble
times have changed so much mom
interjected in a cold voice
you don't say ah well then
what gradient tony bar six have you met
any friends here so far
not yet i'll be going to school for the
first time after the break
and then i'll leave you my number just
in case call me
if you have any new info i looked out
the window
at the road the police uaz drove off
towards the village
the officer's nephew came to mind when i
was splitting off old paint from the
windowsill those delightful lead paint
chips
so tasty i noticed trail of policemen's
footprints that led into the forest
and then it clicked in my head why don't
i start an investigation of my own
maybe i'll find that lost boy and i'll
get a reward
julia will be so happy and not only all
you
mom and dad too maybe they'll even
forget about their quarrels for a while
maybe else even save us from the d word
i fantasized about buying olya
tamagotchi and getting her a cassette
player and a bunch of tapes for myself
a whole box of kinder surprise i
couldn't wait to go out
look for clues i'm going outside
yeah right you want the police to go
around with your photograph next
the forest is so thick what if the boy
got snatched up our wild animals or
something even worse
even worse echoed through the hallway i
won't go far i'll stay away from the
forest
did you hear what i said or should i
repeat myself
better go pack your school bag and play
with olia
the sound of splashing water came from
the kitchen it meant that the argument
was over and mom had the last word
ooh interesting okay so here's the thing
i know it's been a long interlude before
i talk to you guys
i love this story so far i'm super into
it i think it's great but i'm not going
to save ever i just want to see where it
goes
this is the first of five potential
chapters for this game
and it's already off to a good start
also this game was free i think
i may be mistaken about that but editor
confirm with me if that was actually
true
thank you let's open this what is it
here the dark stuffy closet
mom says it smells like mice but how
would she know their smell
she hates when i stick my nose in there
she's afraid i'll cut myself on the
freshly sharpened axe
and i like to hide in the closet and
listen to all you count outside
one two three better hide from me and
then drag her feet on the creaking
floorboards
hoping that she wouldn't need to look
for me in the cramped monsters den
[Music]
well i think that i need to go to this
investigation
i'm going out i opened the front gate
and went into the field carefully so mom
wouldn't see me from the window
when i crossed half the distance towards
the forest the snow piles became as high
as my knees
i remembered my nightly fears in the
light of day
those distant figures felt like a simple
dream
the sun turned my nightmares to ash the
aftertaste was still there
distant ringing in my ears distorted
shadows crawling on the snow alongside
me
and barely audible whisper in my head
blurry
and almost kind everything was silent
so silent i felt like the world was
totally empty
no ground no sky no
yeah i squinted from the sun and turned
my eyes to the sunless forest
it looked especially dark in contrast
with the blinding whiteness
knobbly tree roots slithered under the
snow like fat snakes
rotten leaves and coniferous needles
froze into the ice
some object was hanging from one of the
pointy branches
i tried to get closer drowning in snow
and when i almost got to the edge of the
forest i saw
a knitted mitten it looked like a
wounded bird
among the hungry semi-dark should i take
it to the police
will this mitten help them find the lost
boy
volva
oh someone was standing there behind the
trees
hiding
okay there's no one there just branches
and roots
it's all just my imagination nearby bird
flapped its wings loudly
a shadow split from the tree and
disappeared from my sight i looked away
for just a moment
but when i turned back my gaze to the
same place it was gone
so it was my imagination after all
silence reigned for a painfully long
time
muscles were tightly sprung my heart was
beating somewhere in my throat
any noise any little movement any small
whisper from the thicket and i'd sprint
but nothing of the sort happened
i looked at the mitten once more
i'm taking the mitten i'm getting that
mitten
i decided to take the lonely mitten from
the branch
oh no a shout rumbled across the field
and dissolved into the distance
no echo no hope for a reply
[Music]
oh do i get it now oh i'm going for it i
wouldn't
budge i pulled harder the branch cracked
in the mitten tore off landing in my
hand with a squishy sound
all too heavy wet i squeezed it without
thinking something dark spilled from it
forming a tiny string between the mitten
and the snow steam rose from the snow
pile
i froze in place studying my palms in
disgust
red the sound of cracking branches
invaded the silence
oh i didn't have to think twice before
running away
someone was chasing me from the darkness
breaking pine branches closing the
distance with giant leaps
snow was slowing me down crazy thoughts
flew through my mind
i'll get caught they'll get me i'll get
dragged into the thicket i'll be gone
forever
but there was one more voice probably
one of reason it gave me strength
spurred me on
you can do it don't stop i heard an
animal roar behind me
it was so loud my ears went numb it felt
like the sound had come from a pack of
hungry beasts rather than a single one
their nostrils sucked in freezing air
they sensed my fear
two giant wings slapped above my head an
enormous shadow fall over
glaring a hoot louise the roars were
coming from all directions now
from the dried up raspberry bush from
twisted pines from under the windfall
hurry run don't look back i reached a
clear path with one jump and from there
ran to my house
it's gloomy facade didn't look
threatening now that house was my last
line of defense from the shadows that
flapped their wings
and the creatures that were hidden under
the snow i tripped over the doorstep and
smashed into the door
in all my hurry i still managed to
notice the claw marks as if a dog was
striking the wood with its paws
demanding to be let in so it could
escape the cold i hadn't noticed these
marks when i was leaving
the heartbeat in my ear was much louder
than my surroundings i couldn't hear
whether someone was following me or not
drowning in fear i pulled the doorknob
and it obediently gave way
i rolled into the hallway and shut the
door behind me mom peeked out of the
kitchen and chastised me with the same
frigid voice she always used when
talking to dad
what exactly didn't you understand when
i told you to never slam the door
i i didn't mean to i snuck a glance at
the door
the smell was gone the breath was too
if there was someone in the first place
of course here
mere five meters away from mom my fear
was slowly weakening
melting like snow and spring and with it
the last bit of strength i had left in
my body too
my legs gave way i propped myself up
against the wall so i wouldn't fall over
mom's expression had changed immediately
the cold mask of strictness and
detachment was gone
mom looked the same as before all those
quarrels finally
she saw my condition my wet pants
plastered with snow
and she squinted her eyes in suspicion
and looked into the front yard
her expression changed in an instant and
she covered her mouth with her hand
mom beckoned me with her finger and i
gathered all my remaining bravery to
look into the kitchen window
facing my fear
i can barely discern some hairy
silhouettes in the swimming in the snow
through the icy winter patterns on the
glass
dogs well some detective i am
in reality i wasn't risking my life
among monsters but rather my pants among
a pair a pack of stupid strays
and what for what use do i have for this
mitten
of course a darkened sticky mitten that
belonged to the lost boy made a squishy
sound in my hand
seems like i was clutching it the whole
time that's my trump card as a detective
i hurried to present this clue to my mom
mom look
this is volva's mitten that boy the
police were asking about in the morning
it's drenched in blood i found it
hanging on a tree i can show where
let's call the police right away like
the officer had told us to
mom look stop at this moment or you will
go insane if she hears you
he already has trouble sleeping whines
all the time you joke around like this
at that moment i realized the mitten was
actually wet from snow
there was no blood whatsoever i wanted
to sink through the floor from
embarrassment
come here my boy who cried wolf oh don't
just stand there come take your pills
a golden colored pill reminiscent of a
dead wasp
fell into my palm come on take it or you
won't be able to sleep at night
and you have school tomorrow so i had to
swallow the bitter medication
drinking it down with some similarly
awful water that gave off the taste of
chlorine
maybe it wasn't vova's mitten maybe it
wasn't a mitten at all
just like the forest monsters and all
yazoo
am i going mad what's happening to me
either the pill had an immediate effect
or my overexerted brain didn't
let fear inside anymore serenity washed
over me
bringing yawning indifference along with
it
it seemed like the house had changed the
sofa's fabric became discolored
fingerprints appeared on the bathroom
tiles the light bulbs also felt dimmer
yellower a melody from aladdin could be
heard from the upper floor
all you was done re-watching your
favorite little mermaid episodes and
switched to other tapes
then i went upstairs jafar
and ziago's voices died down
i walked past olivia's bedroom and
slipped into my own
oh
[Music]
oh the forest didn't look as grimy
during the day
grim entangled tree branches in the
distance and the snowy feel between our
house and the forest brought sleepiness
to my eyes
you know it's probably fine it's
probably nothing yeah probably nothing
fine
one of the drawers was empty i had them
in there
i got achievement i sat on the bed
only then i noticed there was someone
behind the curtains
my tired end dropped to the sheets
whether it was due to the medication
i took or the stress i underwent the
room began to contort
as if the wind was blowing the walls out
like a pair of sails
the coroner's the room's corners bent
and undulated the only stable thing in
the whole room was the figure between
the windowsill and the curtains
a flimsy piece of cloth uh was stuck to
my hidden visitor
just like a savant of sorts oh yeah
who else would be standing there i stood
up and licked my dried lips
yeah oh yeah it's so funny i reached
towards the curtains
but dumb but don't beat my heart
controlled by medication
the wind sang in the field with a chorus
of voices
plastic rings rustled against the holder
when i pulled up with curtains
gotcha i knew it was you from the
beginning
a blindingly bright halo lip up lit up
above oh holya's head with the sun
setting as a background
my sister was shining i saw everything
oh really
what did you hide swear that you won't
tell anyone then i'll show you
olya wore a plotting smile i swear on
mom's heart
i know she remembered in one of the
movies about the pioneers we watched
don't say things like that she was
filled with curiosity
that was splashing in her giant eyes i
opened the drawer and all you leaned in
holding her breath
is this someone's mitten she said that
as if she couldn't understand what she
saw
a certain boy lost it and got lost
himself he must be really cold out there
will they find him they will the police
are going house to house search
showing his photo to everybody and why
are they going to houses and not the
forest
are they scared the question caught me
off guard
the police aren't scared of anything
yeah right flashed in my clouded mind
she was piercing the force with
incredibly adult eyes and
uncharacteristic for what if the owl got
him
nonsense and owl won't be able to lift a
human but you know what
i was picking my words with utmost care
i forced them out of my over-exerted
brain
stay away from the forest i think it's
i think it's how should i put it it's
cursed or something
just like in a fairy tale no not like
that
more like in that spooky tape mom and
dad are hiding from us
well you giggled and tugged at my sleeve
tony let's go watch aladdin
fatigue won over my desire to be with my
little sister i was washed over by some
sort of heinous apathy
i'm too tired i don't wanna come on
it's so boring alone and mom is always
busy we can pick a cartoon you haven't
seen before
i know all of our tapes by heart at this
point not all of them
you haven't watched peter pan remember
how you fell asleep in the middle of it
so much happens after that let's go
let's go maybe a bit later
i know let's play hide and seek no yeah
then draw me a dino or you please draw
it draw it
you leave me alone already i blurted it
out without thinking
and then i was immediately taken aback i
never screamed at my little sister like
that
oh you stared at me in shock her lips
started to tremble
a precursor to tears oh i hurried to
prevent all you from crying
all right you win let's go watch
cartoons for a bit i don't wanna
i came up to her put my hands on her
soft head let's go let's watch peter pan
boo you'll fall asleep again i smiled
and lifted her chin her eyes were wet
and felt bottomless
i promise i won't and i'll draw you a
full triceratops later
hooray try tripassara popes
well good enough well you rubbed her
eyes with the sleeve on her pajamas and
shining smile returned to her face i'll
go ask mom for condensed milk and bread
and you rewind the tape
the bread is fresh just how you like it
alright just be careful not to spill the
milk
or you'll be yelled at again want to bet
i won't spill it
the tape is somewhere in the nightstand
look for it oh you disappeared into the
doorway and i dragged my feet into the
neighboring room
got a bad feeling about this the scary
window where all you see is that cursed
owl every night
lurking in the dark oya keeps curtains
open during the day but as soon as the
twilight comes she shuts them tight
so she wouldn't see the pair of hungry
eyes outside
sure
the old photon tv was gathering dust in
the corner
all that was left was clicking the
button on the front panel
the tube warmed up and familiar white
noise started dancing on the black
screen
i almost reached out to turn on the vcr
when the noise calmed down and a blurry
image appeared for a moment
what do you mean it was the dark tiger
forest just like the one outside my
window
the picture split the screen in half
something creepily resembling human
speech was coming out of the speaker
just a few moments later the scenery was
again overshadowed by noise
did it catch some rogue signal local tv
station only really so
showed soviet cartoons and even that was
pretty rare maybe i should tinker with
the antenna
what if i catch this channel again on
the other hand well you asked me to find
the tape
wouldn't be nice to disappoint her but
in my sleepy state i didn't have the
strength to do all of it
really yeah okay all right something
strange going on here
she can find the tape herself oh no
oh that's not good oh that's not good
the picture finally cleared up but the
moment i rejoiced to finding that weird
signal again the tv started coughing
a voice barely coming through the
cacophony he was often seen
at the moment when small snowy hills
were lined up on the screen
pierced with rickety crosses and a male
voice was narrating with a slow mournful
voice
it was a pitch-black knight at the
cemetery in their fateful dark time when
little senior met her fate
at the face of a monstrous thicket
dweller the locals call him none other
than
the forest master i froze i did my best
not to move
as if by doing that i could scare away
the narrator i listened closely to his
every word
the beast dealt with the helpless girl
in a masterful manner
the camera panned across the snow with
something black spilled over it
looking for ragged pieces of cloth that
were thrown all over the place
i didn't want to think whether senya's
remains were wrapped up in there
so i shut my eyes without thinking
the voice continued wolves are rare
guests in these parts
oh is what tamara the old woman that
lives in a nearby crypt had to say
a close-up shot of her face of a home
old homeless woman weary from life and
alcohol abuse rattled on the screen
yes yes how's your fierce and beastie it
is
worse than the rising dead the old woman
splattered saliva all over the
rectangular mic
oh and this stink
it's like the rest of her comparison was
swallowed up by the sound of a horn
i never felt anything like that he was
just standing there
yes right where you stand boy oh and
pierced me with its eyes
right in the middle of the day so huge
that one
with glassy eyes obscenities were
covered by another beep
you know they say if this demon lays its
eyes on you
his statue put you into his bag and
you're done
but he won't touch me likes me it seems
so they even call me the devil's wench
and it's definitely true
the carnivorous monster will not touch
those who fell to the level of forced
beasts
going for the innocent child's blood
instead the forest master's presence has
felt more and more on the outskirts of
our country
torn between believing in what was said
and shrugging it away
i decided to record the remaining part
of the documentary for some reason
i quickly grabbed the tape that was on
top of the oh
and put it in the vcr without even
looking at the cover oh
i bet that was pete pan oh i
re pressed wreck turned to the sound up
and paid attention to the slipping
signal
it's not called the forest master for
nothing all the animals obey it
be they hairy or feathery they're all
precursors for its appearance
if you hear howls in the distance then
it most likely already knows where you
live
if you find animal prints all over your
doorstep and birds watching from the
trees
you better hide sorry coming for you
and if you wake up at night and see a
pair of eyes in your window
that is soon soon
soon soon oh
soon oh god soon oh god soon soon
soon oh god
the tv suddenly went mad and luke the
last word over and over piercing my ears
i got goosebumps all over my spine and
tape ended and was rewinding to the
beginning
sound of rusting rustling tape reminded
me of leaves in the wind in the hello
howl of the beast
i woke from my stupor and pressed the
button
the vcr ejected the tape for a moment i
thought it was stained with saliva
but that was just the light from the
chandelier making the black plastic
glossy
then i saw the cover oops i recorded it
over peter pan
i snuck a glance at the door i could
hear the clatter of glass and the
squeaky floorboards
you appeared in the doorway you haven't
started without me have you
my sister brought the tray with the
unevenly cut bread and a whole can of
condensed milk
uh no i was looking for the tape do you
really want to watch peter pan
i do i do turn it on already mom will
come watch your brazilian drama soon
come think it come on think fake
detective you know i didn't like peter
pan
maybe we should watch the little mermaid
instead i've already seen it so many
times
and you promised me she's so stubborn i
know
let's watch a couple of teenage mutant
ninja turtle episodes first
deal when you oh you frowned but
ultimately gave up
she put the tray down and crossed her
hands on her chest
if you want it so much can you open the
milk can i'm afraid i'll cut myself with
the sharp edges
only when i reached the sofa i realized
that the can was already open
oh yeah it tricked me played me for a
fool my stomach became heavy
i wanted to rush towards the tv but my
little sister was faster
she picked up the remote and proclaimed
in a victorious tone
gotcha gotcha gotcha as the remotest
master i command you to watch peter pan
oh oh no i couldn't even open my mouth
and the vcr
ate the accursed tape i better tell the
truth
oh you stop i erased the end of your
tape by accident
i'll trade it with you for two of mine
what do you mean
you couldn't erase it me and dad had
broken off all those plastic pins with a
screwdriver
you can't record anything over my
cartoons my little
sister pressed the triangular play
button on the remote i squeezed on the
inside
waiting the out of this world voice of
the narrator
but i saw the duel between peter pan and
captain hook instead
i sighed into leaf my head heavy as a
leading ball
now rested in my hands oh you smiled in
joy
she put the tape on rewind and started
spreading milk over her bread
when the cartoon started she forgot
about everything in the world
[Music]
as if she really got transported to the
neverland like she always wished
to be honest i also imagine myself there
in a land where one never ages
or when no one argues over little things
or no one listens to fights
and the sounds of broken plates at night
we followed peter pan's adventures as if
nothing had happened
as if the forest didn't kidnap kids as
if our parents weren't tearing each
other apart bit by bit
captain hook was running away from a
crocodile and captain pan was headed to
london on a gilded sailboat
by some miracle i lasted longer than my
sister
olya's eyelids had drooped she started
snoring slightly
resting her chin on the side of the bed
the chorus was singing the ending song
the world of disney was lit up by a
silvery moon
another moon peeked from under the first
one
scary and won hanging over the tiger
forest
the horrific report got recorded right
over the credits
my throat went dry my pulse became
faster
i squeezed the remote with all my might
ready to press stop at any moment
i rewound the recording checked if it
was intact
and carefully took out the tape the
protective pin was still in place i
stood up
and left all year's room
[Music]
whether it was by providence or by curse
i hid the tape alongside the mitten
at the exact moment mom peeked into my
room
[Music]
enough playing around it's your first
day at school tomorrow
go to bed you should sleep properly you
don't want to be teased for being sleepy
right
[Music]
i covered myself with a blanket up to my
neck and listened to the house humming
to something invisible rustling in the
corners
my inner voice in question for me do i
want to hear that mysterious flute again
yes or no
they went how on and on in the night
my thoughts were like annoying flies
that entered my head before becoming
weak
and tangled i didn't notice how i fell
into slumber
well good yay hey true detective that's
that's me
oh
well there you have it
i guess damn i like that a lot
i really did was a nice change of pace
to a lot of the horror games that i've
been playing lately
really delightful and also just like i
really like the art style the art sale
is super cool
i love i always love this like painting
effect this kind of style this is really
nice
really nice stuff so anyway that is tiny
bunny episode one
really a lot of good work going on here
some pretty cool stuff
can't wait to see what's coming next for
it like if there's gonna be apparently
five episodes of this and
you know it's pretty cool so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below if you want to see more
of this
when it comes out try to support the
developer download this game
tell friends about it i want to see more
of it i want to see how this story pans
out
so thank you and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye